we're here on the ukrainian side of the
border so this is actually ukraine and
what you're seeing here is refugees who
are crossing the border they are going
to walk across into moldova
thousands of people are doing this every
day it is bitterly cold it is windy
people are waiting in line for hours
many have walked a long way
there are mostly women and children and
the elderly who are crossing there are
also some men
like the men that you see behind me here
these men are fighting age so usually
they would have to stay behind but these
particular men are looking for political
asylum in moldova so they will be
crossing and hoping that they are
allowed to leave the country but by far
the vast majority of people who we're
seeing here are women with young
children and the elderly very difficult
weight
certainly in the tent behind us there is
food there is hot soup but it is so
difficult for the people that have made
this journey physically emotionally
people we've been talking to who say
bullets narrowly miss them that they
have gone from city to city that is
being bombed uh basically dodging their
way through ukraine across roads that
are no longer possible to find their way
to this point they have no idea where
they're going to go after this
there is a quiet strength among these
ukrainians as they wait but the trauma
is etched on their faces you can feel
the anxiety of the life they knew
suddenly interrupted by war
and the urgency of their need to get to
safety as they anticipate a renewed
assault on nearby odessa
mercedes stephenson global news at the
polanco border crossing in ukraine